[Music]
my name is Brian Smith and I'm a PhD
candidate in the computer vision lab
here at Columbia and I'm the creator and
the developer of the racing auditory
display the rad and what it is is a way
of making it possible for people who are
blind to play racing games and have the
same sort of experience playing those
games as sighted players time
[Music]
to be able to do things like cut corners
anticipate upcoming turns remember the
track layout and all of the things that
sighted players are used to doing in
racing games it was interesting to try
the rad because of the the new
experience that it gave to me as a
visually impaired person in relation to
playing racing games the rad is a user
interface that can be added to any
racing game it's just a means of givin a
racing game a developer can plug in the
rad and then that will output sound to a
player's headphones to give them
information about the race track and so
just to prove that he is not using the
screen or the visual information the
graphics at all I'm going to turn the
screen away from him
so he's not looking at the screen at all
and yet he's still able to play the game
and even kind of cut this corner this
has turned 17 it's a really long turn
this feeling of I guess you can say the
feeling of adventure that it gave the
sense of control that it gave me as a
player was totally different than what
you would usually get from other audio
racing games that were specifically
designed for the visually impaired
community so right now if you look at
the types of video games that are
available to people who are blind it's a
pretty it's a pretty sparse field
they're very simplified versions of what
sighted people would play they either
cut out a lot of the game mechanics and
higher-level strategies that you might
expect
so in racing games for example there are
no concepts of cutting corners or they
overload the player with too much
information and so here our goal was to
give people who are blind an authentic
experience that they could play racing
games the same way that sighted players
would experience racing games with all
of the information that they would
normally have to decide how to race
themselves without overloading them with
information I am listening to the
different information that I get which
is the sounds of what I'm approaching a
turn
[Music]
we've actually found that the rad helps
people who are blind race as well as
casual sighted players can we compared
lap times from sighted people and blind
participants and they were comparable
now if you have a really good sighted
player they can do better because they
can hug corners just even more precisely
than what the rad would allow you to do
but the fact that like a regular 3d
racing game can be playable by someone
who's blind at a level that's comparable
to sighted players is is a completely
new thing
[Music]